und ich konnte mich heute gar nicht
entscheiden über wen ich mich mehr
aufregen wollte michael kretschmer der
sächsische ministerpräsident der
plötzlich gesagt hat es kann auch jeder
lockdown für alle geben aber dann kam
ein satz der mich noch mehr aufgeregt
hat und zwar von bodo ramelow der ist
ministerpräsident in thüringen und der
hat heute gesagt ich zitiere wir haben
eine pandemie da ungeimpften und wir
werden niemanden mehr garantieren können
der ungeimpft ins krankenhaus kommt dass
er überhaupt noch in thüringen behandelt
wird das muss man sich mal vorstellen so
weit ist es mittlerweile in deutschland
gekommen dass ein ministerpräsident
ungeimpften menschen sagt dass sie
möglicherweise in den krankenhäusern
nicht mehr behandelt werden noch einmal
zur erinnerung es gibt keine impfpflicht
in deutschland es ist die persönliche
entscheidung eines jeden einzelnen ob er
sich eben oder ob er sich nicht in das
sich ein politiker ein ministerpräsident
sogar hinstellt und jetzt am ende eine
triage für ungeimpfte fordert kann man
fast sagen denn wenn ein
ministerpräsident das sagt dann hat das
auch immer konsequenzen für die ärzte
die dort arbeiten und für alle
diejenigen die im gesundheitsbereich
arbeiten ich empfinde das als großen
skandal und als vielleicht noch größeren
skandal dass ich gar nicht so viele
darüber aufregen das scheint schon
völlig normal zu sein dass man jetzt
fordern kann dass man ungeimpfte nicht
mehr behandelt leider reiht sich das ein
in eine echte diskriminierung dieser
menschen der ungeimpften die für sich
persönlich entschieden haben sich nicht
impfen zu lassen und das jetzt dieser
ministerpräsident das sagt das zeigt wo
wir mittlerweile angekommen sind in
deutschland und diese skandal nicht hat
er noch viele kleine skandale in sich
und das macht ihn eigentlich noch größer
herr bodo ramelow hat keine
parlamentarische mehrheit im landtag von
erfurt hat also nicht den
mehrheitswillen der dort wählende
bevölkerung hinter sich zweitens er
führt sehr sehr gerne als linker
sozialist das wort solidarität im und er
kündigt ihre solidarische verhalten
mindestens zwei richtungen auf
einerseits gegenüber den ungeimpften die
sie aber nicht impfen lassen müssen rein
theoretisch andererseits kündigte aber
auch die solidarität gegenüber den
anderen bundesländer auf weil er sagt ja
ihr werdet schon irgendwo behandelt aber
bitteschön nicht in thüringen er sagt
also als thüringischer landesvater die
anderen bundesländern die kümmern sich
um die folgen und das ist der dritte
skandal in diesem großen skandal warum
sagt er das überhaupt weil er als
landesvater als chef der exekutive nicht
dafür gesorgt hat und früher sorgen muss
und zwar prioritär nämlich für die
daseinsvorsorge der erhalt des
grundsatzes gesundheitssystem ist
primäre aufgabe des staates er hat dort
nicht nötige bettenzahl vorgehalten es
gibt zu wenig betten dort zu wenig
personal wir sind im dritten jahr der
korona pandemie und jetzt wirft er die
folgen seines versagens auf die
ungeimpften auf die anderen bundesländer
und auch die krankenhäuser vor ort drei
mal fragt sich auf welcher grundlage auf
welcher grundlage er argumentiert also
die zahlen liegen nicht auf dem tisch
was heißt das dass plötzlich die
intensivstation überfüllt sein sollen
wir wissen es gar nicht ob es stimmt und
wenn das stimmen würde dann das haben
sie gerade gesagt das kommt er jetzt das
fällt ja nicht vom himmel wir wussten ja
dass im herbst das virus unterwegs sein
würde und wieso haben sie nicht
vorgehabt das wirklich eine frage wie
ein jahr sprachlos entschuldigung ich
bin wirklich schockiert ich musste vorab
was sagen natürlich wünsche ich mir dass
die leute sich impfen ich glaube impfung
ist kann uns retten kann daraus
weiterbringen und ich appelliere an alle
die ungeimpften das vielleicht auch mal
zu überdenken und das zu tun aber das
was wir hier sehen diese aussage ist
nicht nur populistisch sondern auch
komplett und demokratisch ich appelliere
hier an der verfassungsschutz darüber
nachzudenken das ist unmöglich also das
ist eine diskriminierung von menschen
dass es gegen die grundlagen des medizin
dass das so überhaupt möglich ist ist
wirklich
integrationsexperte und beim impfen und
der frage wer sich impfen lässt wird
auch immer darüber diskutiert inwieweit
das zum beispiel ein problem darstellt
bei denjenigen die nach deutschland
gekommen sind in den vergangenen jahren
oder auch in der türkischen community
wie nehmen sie das wahr mit nicht nur
also natürlich ist das nicht
eindimensional wir haben ja auch eine
ganz große und
ja fast radikaler gruppierungen von
impfgegner auch in der
mehrheitsgesellschaft aber in allen
europäischen ländern wissen wir dass die
impfquote untermenschen
migrationhintergrund niedriger als im
allgemeinen
bevölkerung und das ist ein thema die
natürlich nicht nur durch aufklärung und
sondern auch durch maßnahmen verändert
werden will aber keiner will darüber
reden weil es ja
diskriminierend überhaupt dafür wären
gibt es da eine begründung gibt es da
eine begründung eigentlich dafür warum
das so ist oder können sie das erklären
er das hat wahrscheinlich auch mit dem
vertrauen gegenüber den start die
menschen nicht in ihren heimatländern
haben und natürlich auch fake news die
auch da auf arabisch und anderen
sprachen natürlich auch sehr verbreitet
sind judith besser du nimmst du die
debatte um geimpfte nicht geimpft war in
diesem tag also ich glaube das größte
problem ist ich glaube dieses regierung
sollte sich einfach mal entscheiden ob
sie eine impfpflicht einführen will oder
nicht weil was im moment jetzt auch
getan wird und diese explodierte immer
versprochen dass wird auf keinen fall
passieren also anlagenbau dieses
versprechen also ich bin komplett gegen
die impfpflicht aber bevor man dann so
dummheit und so versucht die leute so
massiv unter druck zu setzen unter
modischen indem man sie an moralischen
klargestellt und dann wirklich ganz
autoritär ihnen menschenrechte abspricht
auf medizinische behandlung denke ich
mir dann führt doch die impfpflicht
einfach ein bevor man mit solchen
reaktionären und super autoritären
methoden dann seine eigenen bürger
angesagt sie beobachten die politik im
berliner betrieb intensiv halten sie das
für möglich dass man am ende auch
sozusagen von diesem grund versprechen
abrückt und sagt die zahlen sind so
schlimm jetzt brauchen wir die
impfpflicht ich halte es für nicht
möglich weil man eigentlich dann ja
komplett als lügner oder wort brüchiger
politiker da steht man wird also nach
wurfversuchen borussia forsch und was
wird der kretschmer hat gesagt zweig auf
keinen fall gerade jetzt die eilmeldung
jetzt kommt 2 geht ja bis dahin haben
wir neue regierung da ja aber sonst die
richtige aber ich glaube trotzdem an
wird man wird faktisch die bedingungen
so hoch setzen das ja 3 ghz teilweise
schon mit pcr testern für 70 bis 100
euro 2 gegen krankenhäuser dass jetzt
alle familienangehörigen unter druck die
ihre kranken besuchen wollen das heißt
man wird die anti familien rein gehen an
das geld heran gehen so dass letzten
endes viele leute sagen und dann mache
ich es halt